[Musique]
bienvenue au parlement européen à
strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale turquie
aujourd'hui avec cette question faut-il
gelé les négociations d'adhésion avec la
turquie ou au contraire maintenir le
dialogue
les pays européens ont affiché cette
semaine leurs divisions sur l'attitude à
adopter face aux dérives autoritaires du
gouvernement turc à des atteintes aux
droits de l'homme qui se sont
intensifiées depuis le coup d'état
avorté du mois de juillet contre le
président erdogan coup d'état avorté
suivi par des vagues de répression
l'europe qui peine à s'entendre sur la
réponse à y apporter large majorité des
pays européens se refuse cette semaine à
franchir le pas d'une rupture avec
ankara et le contexte la lutte contre le
terrorisme la guerre en syrie et la
gestion des migrations vers l'europe là
le président recep tayyip erdogan
s'impose comme un partenaire central
alors faut-il gelé l'adhésion de la
turquie
on en débat avec nos invités elena
valenciano bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne espagnole membre du groupe
socialiste
mais surtout vous êtes président de la
commission des droits de l'homme ici au
parlement européen connaître ou sylvie
goulard bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée
française du groupe de l'alliance des
démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs du modem merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
enfin samim hague le nul à vous êtes
historien politologue à l'université de
strasbourg et vous suivait de très près
ce qui se passe actuellement en turquie
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
mais d'abord retour en images sur les
atteintes à la démocratie du régime
turquie sont intensifiées depuis le coup
d'état avorté du mois de juillet
françois chevret
[Musique]
c'était le 15 juillet dernier
les avions militaires bombarde le
parlement turc à ankara des chars et des
soldats bloquent le pont d'istanbul et
tirent sur la foule à jeddah hyper doan
échappe à une tentative de meurtre
le lendemain le coup d'état échoué le
président turc eux préparent déjà la
contre attaque
nous allons éliminer le virus de toutes
les institutions publiques car ce virus
s'est propagé comme un cancer le chef
d'état désigne le responsable de cette
tentative de putsch
fethullah gulen exilé aux états unis ce
prédicateur islamiste est à la tête d'un
réseau tentaculaire
il possède des centaines d'écoles en
turquie et il a des partisans dans
toutes les administrations du pays
chaque fonctionnaire suspectait d'avoir
un lien avec les gueux les listes est
incarcéré mises à pied ou limogés le
purge qui touche les enseignants un
millier d'écoles sont fermées
cette manifestation va se poursuivre
jusqu'à ce que nos collègues retrouvent
leur poste il y aura des sit in et des
marches à ankara certains de nos membres
sont prêts à entamer une grève de la
faim
nous allons continuer nos actions
jusqu'à ce que tout le monde retrouve sa
place mais dans la rue pas de place pour
la contestation
la purge s'étend à la société civile
1200 organisations caritatives sont
fermés la presse n'est pas en reste 200
journalistes sont mises en prison
170 médias mettent la clé sous la porte
ceux qui travaillent dans ces médias ne
sont pas ceux qui ont mené le putsch
ils sont les victimes d'un gouvernement
qui utilise le coup d'état pour étendre
son oppression contre ses opposants
l'état d'urgence c'est aussi l'occasion
de s'attaquer à la minorité kurde
début novembre les deux leaders du parti
pro-kurde eux sont mises en garde à vue
et dix autres responsables emprisonné à
y perdre one c'est une entrée en force
de l'islam dans un état jusque-là laïque
en treize ans de pouvoir comme premier
ministre puis comme président il a
supprimé l'interdiction du voile à
l'université
récemment elle a tenté de faire voter
une loi qui permet d'annuler la
condamnation pour agression sexuelle sur
mineur si l'agresseur épouse sa victime
alors c'est cela la turquie qui
progresse bien sûr que non on est contre
cette loi et on ne se taira pas sawicki
karachi
dans son élan le président turc a même
promis une mesure forte
le rétablissement de la peine de mort
[Musique]
voilà et puis un double attentat le week
end dernier a frappé le coeur d'istanbul
au moins 44 morts représailles les
autorités turques ont arrêté près de 300
membres du principal parti pro kurde
il frappait en irak à des cibles de la
rébellion kurde dont un groupe dissident
a revendiqué l'attentât meurtrier
l'escaladent autoritaire d'erdogan n'est
pas prêt de se terminer samim advenu
écoutez souvenez-vous en 2004 dans cette
belle maison que quand les eurodéputés
lever les oui eve est pour l'ouverture
des négociations d'adhésion de la
turquie dans l'union européenne
il ya de l'eau qui a coulé sous les
ponts du bosphore effectivement à partir
de 2010 2011 nous voyons revirement du
régime en turquie à partir du moment où
le gouvernement a pu contrôler
l'entièreté de l'appareil étatique parce
que entre 2002 et 2010 il s'agit d'un
gouvernement mais il existe quand même
un appareil étatique qui peut faire
équilibre vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement a
partout 2010 temps n'est plus le cas et
bien à part de cette date là nous voyons
une montée d'autoritarisme d'une
centralisation du pouvoir
effectivement et ce qui s'est passé à
partir de 7 juin 2015 c'est les
élections qui ont été annulés
effectivement une accélération de cette
de ce régime autoritaire utilisant
maintenant le prétexte la tentative de
coup d'état qu'il faut condamner bien
entendu elle est là valenciano une vague
d'arrestations qui a ciblé le parti
d'opposition pro kurde et les médias
aujourd'hui aussi un plus de 130
journalistes sont derrière les barreaux
en turquie sein c'est plus que qu'en
chine et en iran réunis est-ce que
erdogan a atteint son but c'est à dire
museler ceux qui le critiquent
il semble qu'il n'a pas d'un sens du but
puisqu'il continue à exercer une forte
répression sur quiconque ose lever la
voix s'est pas seulement c'est aussi des
professeurs c'est aussi des
fonctionnaires publics
les membres du hd pays à 7400 membres du
rhdp qui on était partis d'opposition a
conclu opposition troisième parti au
parlement
ce sont nos camarades qui ne peuvent
plus venir à nos réunions
internationale parce qu'ils sont en
prison et donc j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'a pas là du tout l'intention de
s'arrêter là la réponse à laquelle
erdogan devrait répondre
et est ce que vous voulez adhérer à
l'union européenne
parce que si c'est le cas le chemin
qu'il a entrepris et justement le
contraire tout ce que l'union européenne
trouve à dire face à ces développements
c'est que cela suscite des inquiétudes
est-ce que c'est suffisant face à ces
personnes qui sont in emprisonnés non on
assiste et encore une fois je n'ai
aucune sympathie pour les personnes qui
organisent des putschs dans des régimes
ce qui s'est passé était assez confus
cet été mais il semblerait qu'il ya
quand même eu des personnes qui ont
essayé de militairement porter atteinte
à l'ordre démocratique kurde je n'ai pas
de sympathie pour ça mais là on assiste
à une violation caractérisée des
principes de la démocratie et de l'état
de droit avec des emprisonnements
arbitraires de juges de fonctionnaires
de deux journalistes
et c'est une violation je le dis
d'autant plus qu'on est à strasbourg
convoi par la fenêtre la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme c'est la violation
par la turquie d'engagement qu'elle a
pris depuis 1949
puisque la turquie est également membre
du conseil de leur organisation
internationale indépendante de l'union
européenne et dont le but est la
promotion des droits de l'homme
donc il faut qu'on arrête de penser que
c'est un contributeur
pardon et la turquie et grands
contributeurs que le grand financeur du
conseil le oui mais et même le respect
de l'état de droit je ne respect des
dates qui joue tout son rôle dans le
sens de la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme c'est à dire pour la
promotion d'un état de droit des
principes fondamentaux de l'égalité
homme-femme de la non discrimination etc
donc il faut arrêter cette hypocrisie
qui consiste à penser que c'est en
promettant l'adhésion à l'union
européenne où on l'a maintenant en
quelque sorte artificiellement en vie
qu'on règle la question droit pour la
question droits de l'homme il ya
d'autres instruments et pacta sunt
servanda la turquie doit respecter les
engagements qu'elle a pris encore une
fois après la seconde guerre mondiale
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'union
européenne personnellement je suis très
à l'aise parce que je ne faisais pas
partie des gens qui tenaient des
pancartes ce que j'ai écrit un bouquin
en mineur en 2004 qui s'appelait le
grand turk et la république de venise
dans lequel à l'époque j'ai essayé
d'analyser non pas seulement ce qu'était
la turquie comme font tous les gens on
la regarde à la loupe
mais ce qui est l union européenne est
ce qu elle essayer d'offrir
et à mon avis a dépassé totalement les
forces et la capacité de l'union
européenne à ce moment là déjà
vous étiez contre l'adhésion d'une
éventuelle adhésion de la turquie à
l'union rappelle déjà à l'époque oui
parce que la turquie pas parce que
l'union européenne et on l'a vu dès avec
les agissements précédent a aussi du mal
à rester une europe politique une europe
sociale si elle s'étend de manière
inconsidérée ont personnellement je suis
très à l'aise quand je suis très triste
pour la société civile turque
il y a encore des gens qui se battent
soit en turquie soit à l'extérieur je
pense à chandler par exemple qui est
exilé en allemagne qui est l'ancien
rédacteur en chef de comus rillettes les
lavallois fait réagir oui moi c'est le
contraire c'est à dire moi j'ai toujours
été pour l'adhésion de la turquie à
l'union européenne
je crois que qu'il y avait en turquie
déjà à ce moment là une société civile
très vive et très très proches très
proches à non à nos valeurs et qui
avaient besoin absolument d'une main
pour pour justement venir de ce côté là
disons du côté de la démocratie de
l'état de droit du pluralisme et cetera
j'ai toujours été une grande défenseure
des de cette situation et c'est erdogan
qui me fait justement revenir en arrière
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la carotte
elle augmente et le bâton de l'union
européenne ne fonctionnent plus parce
que du côté du régime non plus il n'ya
pas une volonté bien au contraire il ya
un discours d'altérité très très fort
identitaire essentialiste qui alimente
ailleurs le discours identitaire et
essentialiste de ce côté-ci de l'arabe
ailleurs la montée de la droite
populiste n'est pas uniquement n'est pas
l'apanage de la turquie quand on regarde
le monde occidental le monde entier peut
être il y ait cette tendance et c'est
très très grave
je pense que nous avons raté cette
occasion j'espère que cette fenêtre de
tir s'ouvrira à bombay dans un avenir
proche mais en tout cas pour l'instant
ça ne sent pas trop le cas encore une
fois j'ai aucune sympathie avec la
droite populiste utilise des arguments
xénophobes religieux mais très
sincèrement je ne crois pas que la
conception de la souveraineté nationale
qui celle de la turquie où un secondaire
de gamme et d'un certain nombre de
personnes ni l'état de l'union
européenne en ce moment permettent
permettez et permettent d'envisager
j'ai un accord qui serait un accord
gagnant gagnant il y as énormément dépôt
crise' il ya énormément de gens qui du
côté européen ont voulu faire miroiter
des perspectives pour faire évoluer la
turquie sans avoir en rien l'intention
de la faire entrer dans l'union
européenne ni surtout de donner la libre
circulation des personnes ce qui moi à
l'époque me choqué profondément parce
que même ceux qui à l'époque était pour
en général était très réticent sur ce
volet là et il ya eu aussi des arguments
de politique intérieure dans un certain
nombre de pays dans lesquels des gens
ont essayé d'acheter le vote de vote des
ressortissants d'origine turque de
l'heure de leur état par l'est de
l'allemagne
en l'occurrence le la gauche allemand
n'a pas n'a pas résisté à cette
tentation là malheureusement à l'époque
encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de faire miroiter des choses qui
ne qui ne peuvent pas être en revanche
très sincèrement il faut qu'on trouve de
bonnes relations
sur une autre base est aussi encore une
fois jeudi en respectant déjà les
engagements qu'on a personnellement je
suis ravi que la turquie soit dans le
conseil de l'europe
ça permet sur la peine de mort ça permet
sur la liberté d'expression où la
liberté religieuse parents d'avoir un
socle commun
vous étiez pour l'adhésion de la turquie
à l'union européenne
quand on voit le climat actuel dans les
pays européens la montée de la
xénophobie war 2 2 de l'islamophobie
faire entrer un pays de plus de 80
millions d'habitants la turquie
musulmans pour la plupart ce que c'est
pas juste impossible d'ailleurs aucun
état européen dit je veux que la turquie
adhère à lui l'europe est en ce moment
en ce moment je vais pas un jeu de dupes
moment je crois que c'est un discours
impossible ce ne l'était pas à l'époque
et je trouve qu'en effet on a perdu
beaucoup de temps en tout cas il n'y a
pas une seule turquie non plus c'est pas
seulement qui a pas que qu'erdogan il ya
aussi les citoyens turcs mais en plus ya
pas une seule turquie
il y en a plusieurs quand vous quand
vous visitez la turquie et vous et vous
rencontrez les universitaires les
journalistes beaucoup de personnes très
sensibles à la lutte pour la démocratie
vous vous rendez compte que l'europe
pourrait jouer un très bon rôle dans
cette région mais finalement finalement
c'est une solution par exemple mais
antoine jouer ce rôle
cologna est un très bon cadre pour faire
évoluer les choses vers la démocratie
l'état de droit et tant que c'est
possible il faut essayer en ce moment
avec la turquie
cette maison ce parlement a dit qu'il
faut arrêter il faut arrêter qu'il faut
voir quelle est l'évolution qui pour
l'instant très négatif du gouvernement
erdogan
mais pourquoi pas erdogan pas retirer un
jour et on retrouverait une turquie qui
fasse possible cette alliance avec une
europe et monsieur a raison il suffit
pas de faire rentrer les pays dans
l'union pour régler les problèmes
et franchement il ya deux poids et deux
mesures dans notre discours sur les
valeurs et sur les droits fondamentaux
personnellement je suis préoccupé de ce
qui se passe dans certains pays de
l'union européenne je le dis aussi pour
la france
le dernier rapport du rapporteur sur la
les tables contrôleur général des
prisons sur l'état des prisons en france
n'est pas à la hausse à la gloire de la
république donc encore une fois on se
soumet à des contrôles internationaux et
on s'y soumet tous dans un esprit
positif consistant à dire partout il ya
des problèmes on les règle soit on est
dans la stigmatisation d'un peuple et je
crois qu'il faut passer d'autres garçons
de l'autre façon de tourner le dos à la
turquie n'est pas jeu il me semble que
ce n'est pas une solution non plus
longtemps que politologue et historien
vous y avez cru que c'était de cette
adhésion
c'est un serpent de mer mais moi j'y
crois toujours ouais j'y crois toujours
évidemment ni la turquie ni l'union
européenne sont des entités statique
elle évolue en interaction elle évolue
en ayant des influences l'une sur
l'autre d'ailleurs je trouve que le
dernier accord entre l'europe et la
turquie au sujet des dix réfugiés qui ne
sont pas des réfugiés d'ailleurs que
n'ont pas de statut de réfugié est
impétueux d'accord à mon sens
faux techniquement et d'en parler et
inique et donc des arguments à ce
pouvoir pour faire pression sur le pays
où on va en parler donc faire face aux
attaques multiples contre les droits de
l'homme du président radouane une
résolution visant à geler le processus
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union a été
votée en riposte le président turc joue
sur la possibilité d'ouvrir à nouveau la
route de l'europe aux migrants on
regarde et on réagit juste après avec
nos invités
[Musique]
il est en colère recep tayyip erdogan le
président turc a pris la parole pour
réagir à la décision prise par le
parlement européen qui demande le gel
des négociations d'adhésion de la
turquie à l'union européenne
erdogan a brandi la menace des migrants
l'homme sait qu'il a entre les mains un
véritable moyen de pression quand
cinquante mille migrants s'étaient
amassées à la frontière entre la turquie
et la bulgarie
vous les européens vous avez crié à
l'aide vous avez compté sur la turquie
pour qu'elle ferme ses frontières si
l'europe continue à nous mépriser ses
frontières nous allons les ouvrir
mettez vous bien ça dans la tête il ya
trois semaines
le parlement européen a demandé le gel
des négociations d'adhésion en raison de
la féroce répression turque depuis le
coup d'état avorté de juillet vote
purement symbolique
cette décision n'appartient qu'aux états
membres c'est l'avis du premier ministre
turc qui réagit aussitôt le vote du
parlement européen pour lui un vote sans
valeur de notre point de vue cette
décision est insignifiante nos relations
actuelles avec l'union européenne ne
sont pas de toute façon tellement
rapprochées l'union européenne doit
comprendre cela l'europe at-elle une
vision de son avenir avec la turquie ou
sans la turquie
elle doit prendre une décision là-dessus
en mars la turquie et l'union européenne
ont conclu un pacte qui a permis
d'assécher le flux de clandestins vers
l'europe si la menace de rouvrir les
frontières et crédibles le président
erdogan prend le risque s'il mettait ses
menaces à exécution de perdre un levier
important son statut de partenaire
indispensable de l'europe
celui qui fait de lui un homme fort de
la scène internationale
[Musique]
voilà on vient de voir le président
obama il sait qu'il a entre les mains un
véritable moyen de pression est ce que
cette menace
elle est crédible vous voulez pas de moi
voulait pas de nous en europe je vous
envoie les migrants c'est pas tout à
fait l'esprit des traités européens
sincèrement bien entendu les autorités
européennes pas le parlement consulter
avec un vote des députés je tiens à le
dire mais les autorités européennes ont
fait cet accord avec la turquie dans des
conditions vous avez raison tout à fait
douteuse
il n'est pas illégitime de son point de
vue de changer à cette hypothèse
mais si on commence à être dans de la
menace mutuelle on n'arrivera à rien il
y à aussi l'accès au marché européen
pour les produits tueur donc on peut se
balancer à la figure ce genre
d'amabilités c'est pas comme ça qu'on
règle les questions internationales
aussi grave que le sort de millions de
personnes dont certains sont des des
personnes qui fuient la guerre d'autres
sont des migrants économiques
moi je crois qu'il faut que tout le
monde on redescend d'un cran le
parlement a simplement parlé d'un gel
des négociations notamment à cause de la
menace d'abandonner la peine de mort et
monsieur erdogan
enfin de l'abolition de la peine de mort
sur deux gars ne sait très bien que ça
fait partie des conditions qui avaient
été posés ce la ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir
l'abolition de la peine de le
rétablissement de la peine de mort c'est
là j'ai l'impression que les menaces
d'erdogan ne sont pas ne sont pas réels
si finalement il a fait tout un discours
au sujet de la solidarité avec les
migrants qui ne qui ne semble pas très
très profond
si maintenant la menace c'est d'ouvrir
et les portes en tout cas moi je n'ai
pas été du tout d'accord avec cet accord
qui a été fait par les gouvernements et
que le parlement n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas
visé disons mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
élections qui arrivent bientôt en
allemagne en france et les gouvernements
veulent garder quand même
erdogan va faire ce qu'il dit cox qui
prononce comme menace il aura aussi des
conséquences dont il vaudrait mieux
qu'il abaisse un peu de trouver de tout
ce temps tout ça les victimes
principales ce sont ces pauvres gens qui
sont déplacés de force et qui sont en
train de fuir exactement la même
violence qui fait peur bobo normes aux
pays européens dans notre marché de noël
à strasbourg dans nos vies bien
confortable donc ils sont devenus des
obligé de marchandages de tapis d'une
côté entre régimes qui devient de plus
en plus autoritaire de l'autre côté une
europe qui a toujours peur de ces
migrants et qui a peur que les
gouvernements vont perdre les élections
parce qu'il ya la montée de cette
extrême droite et la droitisation delà
de la gauche est bien
enfin les victimes sont les mêmes ces
centaines de milliers de gens le petit
enfant sur la plage de la quillane après
de bodrum où je passe mais mes vacances
sur la plage ou mort qui nous a tous
émus il y en a un par semaine
aujourd'hui on n'en parle plus parce que
nous avons cet accord cet accord là je
tente tu t'en tiens j'en prends un on ne
sait pas quels critères plus une
promesse d'argent
bonjour c'est une responsabilité des
gouvernements abolit les frontières
entre nous ce qui est une bonne chose
qui favorise le commerce et les échanges
il est évident qu'à ce moment là nous
devons avoir une politique de contrôle
de nos propres frontières est aussi
trouvant des solutions pour des cas qui
sont humainement tout à fait désespérer
et vous avez raison d'insister sur le
fait que les êtres humains peuvent pas
devenir une monnaie des changes pour les
relations internationales un peu aigre
de l'ue de la russie c'est ce qui était
faux dans cet accord de jouer ou pas
posé cette question à votre os compass
ou si c'est est ce que vous savez ma
venue vous n'êtes pas un peu minoritaire
en étant pro européen pro démocratie en
turquie
quand on regarde de plus près la société
turque la la turquie la turquie version
istanbul par rapport à la turquie
continental l'anatolie la turquie
asiatique qui est plutôt musulmane
pratiquante conservatrice qui aiment les
hommes forts les âmes autoritaire un peu
à l'arrière de vannes est-ce que ce que
fait air doan sais c'est pas la revanche
du sultan ottoman du sultan erdogan
contre mustafa kemal atatürk qui prônait
une turquie plus moderne en utilisant
les mêmes outils
autrement dit en réalité il peut y avoir
véritablement une impression
d'opposition entre l'égypte et hyper
douanes et moustapha kamal attaturk mais
en réalité les outils qu'ils utilisent
dont ils disposent sont similaires et
pratique et 6000 ha pour des buts
objectifs opposés ce que je suis
minoritaire peut-être que je suis
minoritaire mais si ma mémoire est bonne
le quatrième critère de copenhague c'est
le respect des minorités
justement dans une dans une démocratie
il peut y avoir des dissidences des
opinions contraires au régime
et ça n'est pas suffisant pour remettre
en prison pour avoir une répression pour
l'ensemble de la société civile les
universitaires qui avons signé au natal
pour la paix 1128 universitaire et tout
ce que mes collègues qui sont en turquie
sont en très mauvaise position ils ont
perdu leur travail leur travail certains
ont été emprisonnés d'autres ont fui on
tourne dans l'exil
aujourd'hui en europe occidentale et
bien effectivement si nous sommes en
minoritaire il faut nous écouter aux
minoritaires et la manette chesnoff j'ai
pas la démocratie le jeu de la
démocratie mais avoir on peut avoir une
légitimité d'origine et puis la perdre
pendant l'exercice
c'est ce qui fait un an qu'ils attendent
et la démocratie c'est pas d'exterminer
ou d'emprisonner opposant faut quand
même et vous avez tout à fait raison
d'abord je signale que chaque fois qu'il
ya des dérives autoritaires le respect
doit aller à ceux qui résistent pas ceux
qui utilisent leur position dominante
pour écraser les autres donc on peut on
peut être de l'avis de monsieur erdogan
ou pas dans un système démocratique
échanger des arguments au parlement
c'est une chose quand des forces
d'opposition sont muselés quand les gens
sont frappés quand ils sont emprisonnés
c'est une atteinte aux droits de l'homme
qui n'a aucune justification jamais et
lui justifie un peu à cause du
terrorisme et moi je veux dire que moi
je vais sur les propos de leurs deux
amis qui a construit la démocratie en
même temps qu'elle luttait contre le
terrorisme l'espagne et donc on a
construit notre démocratie moderne en
luttant contre le terrorisme et on n'a
jamais franchi la ligne delà de la
démocratie donc c'est pas ce n'est
jamais une justification
c'est vrai qu'il ya des problèmes en
tout cas très graves de sécurité mais ça
ne peut pas être le grand parapluie pour
mettre dessus tout la route la
répression des civils
sinon ce sont les terroristes qui
gagnerait si c'est là surtout qu'il faut
que les démocrates
encore une fois ne soit pas naïf
les dangers il ya des gens à poursuivre
qu'ils ont des projets de mort mais ça
n'est pas une raison pour retenir leurs
méthodes comme légitime quand on connaît
donc le climat actuel dans les pays
européens donc la montée de la
xénophobie voire est ce que cette
adhésion de la turquie est possible ce
sera le mot de la mode la phase que vous
y croyez ou c'est un voeu pieux
finalement on l'est on les fait rêver
avec avec cette possibilité d'adhésion à
l'union européenne alors que là ça
n'arrivera jamais plus personne ne rêve
en ce moment en ce moment ce n'est pas
une possibilité facile ni proche mais je
crois que la direction pourrait se
maintenir
je pense que l'élargissement n'est pas
le seul instrument dont nous disposons
accueillir un pays dans l'union
européenne c'est une possibilité
on peut aussi vouloir vous n'y croyez
pas du tout aussi jamais cru dont je le
dis avec beaucoup de jeudi à parlons
franchement je le dis avec beaucoup de
et je renvoie mes écrits anciens qui
sont dans un contexte où on voyait déjà
les dangers du du personnage air dollars
mais que j'ai écrit à l'époque mais
encore une fois moi je suis très attaché
par exemple à une évolution démocratique
du maghreb pour lequel on n'a jamais
envisagé de donner l'adhésion à l'union
européenne donc il faut bien qu'on
invente d'autres instruments de
relations pour être proche pour
promouvoir nos valeurs pour dialoguer il
n'y a pas que c'est le problème c'est
qu'avec la turquie on l'avait envisagé
et donc c'est un changement par rapport
à la dégradation ou la non intégration
le discours politique en europe ne doit
pas être identitaire essentialiste soir
la mesure où quand on a des approche
culturaliste et les ornières de turquie
qui sont ici des citoyennes français
allemands hollandais belges se sentent
totalement exclues de la société parce
qu'il y a un discours d'altérité
vis-à-vis d'eux mêmes et ils peuvent
justement les chauffer au cinéma joue
ces instruments identitaire monsieur
ardoines place sa politique sur un
discours identitaire sunnites contre
allées vite sûrs contre kurdes musulmans
contre les laïcs et si nous mêmes nous
adoptons le même discours ambiant
j'avais gardé terrain
au mot de la fin vous y croyez vraiment
c'est-à-dire algues sud mais bien
entendu je crois fermement en faisant
évoluer à la fois l'union européenne et
la turquie
je regrette beaucoup la décision de
bréxent it je trouve que c'était une
erreur et je pense que les britanniques
aussi penser
merci en tout cas à vous trois d'avoir
accepté notre invitation c'est un sujet
compliqué mais aussi passionnant un des
rapports entre la turquie et l'europe
mercia à vous de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin d'euro penneteau on se retrouve
l'année prochaine en 2010 est toujours
ici au parlement européen d'ici là
passez de bonnes fêtes bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bail
[Musique]